there is there a test brand you recommend over others for food allergies. I prefer highly
prefer the Syrex lamb, C-Y-R-E-X. If you're one of our course members you which our course is
our 50 bucks you guys right now but you could order labs through the course but we do not have any
up price for our labs so we don't make one penny off our lab so you you could order the
your course member you could order a lab through the course and then if you want to go over it then
you have to pay to talk to me to go over it. The Syrex 10 lab the Syrex array 10 is the food sensitivity
panel but that's assumed that the person is already gluten free because it doesn't test for all the
gliated peptides so take a step back to understand that so gliated is the protein in gluten but
the protein in gluten gliated is a very long chain protein so a protein is a chain of amino acids
a sequence of amino acids that's what a protein is. I don't remember how many amino acids are in
gliated but it's you know well over 100 and then when you eat that gliated that gluten you know
that bread that you're eating that gliated protein gets broken down through enzymes so you have enzymes
secreted by your pancreas that basically act like scissors and cut off that protein so if you
think of that chain of amino acids kind of like a like a pearl necklace so it's this necklace with
you know 150 different pearls on it it's cutting the enzymes are cutting out that pearl necklace
in the sections well a section of a protein is called a peptide so you could have a 15 chain peptide
a 27 chain peptide a 10 chain peptide and you shouldn't have any of these peptides get across they
should all be too big to get across your gut order unless they're only two amino acids long or smaller
so ultimately you know every protein that you eat you in a perfect world we wouldn't have food
sensitivities because if we didn't have any gut damage the proteins that we eat would get broken
down to amino acids now they're not recognized as gliated or gluten or dairy or egg or anything else
they're just amino acids so then those amino acids single amino acids get absorbed across the gut
order then your body uses those amino acids to create enzymes to create other proteins to create
whatever that cell needs for that cell to function so our cells use amino acids they're not using
peptides nor are they using proteins from food sources we are supposed to eat food it's supposed to
break down into amino acids we absorb the amino acids that our cells use those amino acids to make
the correct proteins the correct enzymes from those amino acids that we need to function
problem is is when we have damaged gut walls we have things get across the gut wall that are larger than
you know two amino acids about the together for the diapeptic they're larger peptides or they're
full proteins so some of the some of the people will some people have contact with me go
although i've had a food sensitive tested before and i'm not sensitive to gluten well let me
look at the test well it's only a graded test but graded is this hundred chain you know amino acid
you have to have a pretty darn damaged gut for that size of amino acid to get across the gut wall
for your body to make antibodies against for you then to show positive antibodies against
gliated as it as an intact protein so then we if that was the case we know you have a really bad
damaged gut both the time you have antibodies against the peptides so there's not very many labs
that will test for the gliated peptides so that's why i recommend the Syrex labs so if you go hey i'm
already gluten free already i just need to see what other foods that i had sensitive against well then
i'd say do the Syrex array 10 but if the person's like well i'm not gluten free but i don't have
gut issues then you got to start with the Syrex array three and then go to the Syrex array four
and then to the Syrex array 10 and they do have a bundle package where you can do all of those together
because many times the person won't go gluten free unless you can prove that they have antibodies
to peptides it proved that this and every time you eat this you start to fire if you're gut you need
to deal with that you need to call that down so that's why you need to do that so Syrex tests for
those different peptides so some people will go on you know this other lab it's much less expensive
so i'd rather do that once much less expensive for a reason so if you really want to get you really
want to get better and you really want to dig into your health and you've got to spend a little bit more
and get good lab stuff otherwise you're not going to get good answers if you don't get good answers
you're going to be very frustrated you're going to have questions like some of the people here do
like i've been dealing with this for x amount of years and nobody could figure me out but maybe nobody
could figure out because they're not doing the right tests so again if you don't ask the right
questions you're not going to get the right answers so